welcome back Chris waters here on the
gamespot stage for a demo of freedom
wars now I was checking out the trailer
for this game and it really paints a
terrible dystopian picture of the future
Nick from Sony is here to tell us about
it make it looks horrifying oh well you
know horrifying but awesome at the same
time that is the best kind of horrifying
that's what I think too all right so
freedom wars and title isn't tell us a
whole lot about the game but like this
is like a very specific setting very
evocative and but also still connected
to the modern-day world despite being
like a hundred thousand years in the
future yes that that's right so imagine
like kind of like a post-apocalyptic
society where the remains of humanity
all live in these giant city states
called panopticon ok so the game's
actual code name was panopticon so
that's where that comes from everything
that you do in these city states is
being it's under surveillance all of the
things that I do all the things you do I
just a lot of things I don't and who
have no rights so you have no rights to
do anything I like rights and that's
that's tough all right however here nah
I'll go with it yeah this the
city-state's going to give you the
opportunity to earn those rights and
earn your freedoms back and that's what
freedom wars is so it's you actually
fighting to earn your freedom back thus
the title freedom wars alright so this
guy at least has the freedom to wear
earphones yeah but what is so how can
freedom even exist in a society where
you're just observed all the time and
your lawn ever down everything is earned
everything is earned so actually right
now we're about to see four players
going in to take on a mission given to
us by this central authority to rescue
some civilians that's us paying our debt
to society the one thing I should
mention is that all these people are
actually prisoners they have a million
year sentence of penal servitude that
they have to get past in order to
actually earn their freedom but you know
typical games like this for player kind
of hunting games that you've seen before
yeah aren't really heavy on story
complete opposite here story is robust
it's super interesting you're going to
find out all about the world what
happened and why you have to fight for
your freedom when you play through
freedom wars alright so we got four
players here one of them is the you know
the player who's running the demo are
the others
actual players join yes actual players
joining this is actually a four player
co-op mission that you'll see the end
what system are we playing it on a PS
vita vita loofah bar Vita super block
yep and the game will be fully
compatible with the PlayStation TV as
well so looking forward to that you know
the game has four player ad hoc and
online co-op modes and an eighth player
online competitive mode as well so you
talked about triple-a we're talking
about like big Vita games they don't get
much bigger than this all right so
you're heading out you're trying to
recapture three civilians yep I this I
mean I guess we're gonna get a look at
combat pretty similar what is who are
you who are you a raid against isn't the
certainly if you're trying to earn your
freedom from the governing of force or
you're not fighting authority figure so
actually the panopticon czar kind of at
war with each other so resources are
scarce one of the biggest resources we
have are actually people so one of the
other city-states is actually abducting
people and taking them away so these big
enemies that you see on the screen in
front of you these are abductors and
they actually have civilians inside
their chest cavities so the goal here is
not going to be only to defeat the
enemies but to actually get those
civilians out and transport them out to
extract them so that does I mean you
know being observed in your remote
movement in motion does not sound like a
great fate but you're not inside the
belly of some sort of horrible beasts at
well yes sure so actually what you see
right now is is one of our characters
using the thorn it's actually a really
cool item that's gonna let us do pretty
much every every great thing in battle
it's gonna let us not only have you no
more mobility and you know able to whip
ourselves to it to and fro but it's
gonna let us actually constrict the big
enemies pull them down or also let us
get on top of the enemies and hack at
them to try and get those civilians free
so you know you might be familiar with
other games and everything's just kind
of on foot this is definitely a game
where you're going to be jumping around
moving back and forth it kind of reminds
me in a lot of ways of attack on titan
if you're familiar with that oh yeah
yeah so like we're really honestly all
the different weapon types we have its
goes to cater to a very international
community so that everybody can get in
this and have a good time so you've got
some verticality it has leveled with it
foot that thorn was it this is for
players and each player actually has an
accessory an AI companion that's there
to help you as well as keep an eye on
you so if you actually break a rule or
break a law they're going to be the ones
that actually add more time on to your
million year sentence so we very so you
I guess that's sort of fitting with you
you're observing all the time they up
this AI accessory is along not to help
you guys battle but to keep you in law a
little bit of boat a little bit a little
bit about so what would breaking a lot
like look like is it you know that's on
the circle button it's a powerful attack
but you know how to do it for example
when you start out the game you're in a
very small area and the first one of the
rules you have is that you can't take
more than five steps without contacting
someone so when you do that a big a red
mark will come on the screen and say you
know law broken ten years out of their
sentence and she'll tell you what you
did wrong so every right that you want
every freedom you will gain you will
earn as you play through here so it's
the way it is is a right freedom sort of
like that sort of like an ability is a
comp roughly comparable to it to a skill
or an ability of super guy I would say
it's more like getting a more expanded
map to go around like the hub area or
what you can do your basic battle
abilities will be there from the start
of the game so it's not going to be like
you can only attack one way or do
something but you will gain you know I
guess the ability to craft weapons and
do all sorts of different things as well
so you know honestly everything in the
game you're going to earn you're going
to earn the right to save the game as
well so buckle way to save your yeah
luckily that comes pretty early
hopefully uh so so right now here you
are like yeah and this like now I see
sort of your reference to attack on
titan yeah we're actually on top using
which which means like cutting off the
enemy's arm and picking it up to
basically gain an item that we can use
for crafting weapons afterward oh you
know part of the Beast must be wasted
exactly exactly and you'll see here in a
few moments they're actually going to
start attacking that yellow section in
the middle of his chest to try and get
the civilian out one where the civilian
is yeah can you shed a little more light
on the origin of this like weird phone
and see new beasts well he is I can't
say too much about it because that would
go into story things I can't talk about
but he has been sent by another city
state to basically abduct people and
bring them back alright so you've got
boring ten off the commons yes exactly
very i right so right now we're actually
looks like it's hacking off the the top
part of this abductor and then we're
gonna go around here and try and get
this civilian free that you see right
here so again it's not only that word
we're defeating this enemy but we're
trying to get the civilian out and
actually you'll notice as soon as we get
the civilian out this abductors gonna
start to rage at us and he's going to
come at us like a very angry monster so
it's gonna be the goal of the player to
try to get them to the extraction point
and the teammates are going to be
instrumental in helping him do that so
so one person's on X drags and then the
others are tripping a busy exactly and
it's a very heavy football I should say
so like when you're when you're running
with them you actually have to be
careful you don't drop them um yeah
that's probably all gonna work out under
the
billionaire now and anything you kind of
run into will make you drop them so
mobility is very hampered you have to be
very careful and you have to really rely
on your teammates to help you accomplish
your goals well so speaking of the team
mate over Twitter out alastair son fires
curious about is there sort of classes
or abilities to differ between the
different characters so no you're going
to be able to customize your character
from the second you start the game but
those are customizable things you can do
to your character it's all kind of
aesthetic you'll be able to craft
whatever weapons you want and as you
know despite what your character looks
like you'll be able to use them
effectively in battle you can carry two
weapons into battle at a time it can be
two swords it can be a gun on a sword it
can be whatever you want it to be and we
have a nice variety of bazookas sniper
rifles machine guns you know knives all
sorts of things to get the job done
then are there other mobility tools in a
different in addition to that sort of
thorn bars on it sort of with the thorns
very central to it but you are going to
be able to upgrade your thorn as you
play the game to do different things
don't be able to charge it up to do some
different things but like honestly the
very basic mobility that you see on
display here is kind of representative
of like I would say you know normal
mobility that you'll have in the game so
right so now we're making our way
towards the extraction point you have to
miss mission and this is just one of
three civilians that's right rescue it's
a 15-minute mission you can see these
guys there's actually two abductors
there right now that's so so that's the
other civilian that you're gonna want to
get but yes once you sort of transport
this one away what you got is to do yep
this sort of ties into a question from a
mano Henry on Twitter wondering how long
is this sort of story mode gonna take
you to play through so that's the whole
market I asked I can't really talk if
you're familiar with how long some more
recent RPGs are I'd say it's it's it's
white substantial in that fit ballpark
so you know 20 30 40 maybe maybe maybe
somewhere around there i can't i can't
officially say no fair enough but in you
know what i think about some of these
games is that a lot of times the
single-player content is a little bit
lacking it gets a little bit of a slog
to do by yourself but that's completely
not the case here there's a very robust
an interesting story you're going to
figure out everything that's going on in
the world just by playing through it and
reducing that sentence you have and that
ties a new question from eric song
wondering about to yeah i need to be
online to play freedom or do i have to
be playing multiplayer no no you don't
when you're playing in the single-player
mode you're actually going to have some
awesome characters that are part of your
party you're going to be able to assign
tasks to and take on these bosses you
know these big enemies like multiple at
a time
is it the same whether you're playing
single or multiplayer is at the same
campaign or is there are their differing
sort of hats so I was kind of liking it
to the way a lot of these kind of games
word where to complete the story you'll
have to do certain missions and then you
can always replay those missions with
multiple people involved if you want but
the single-player mode is a single
player mode that is there for you to
take on windy with the AI but you know a
million years sentence you're gonna want
to get some friends to help you take
that down because it might take a while
all right and there goes sound goes
another one and you know well that thing
on your back even kind of looks like the
attack on tight yeah directional yeah a
little bit it has your part your barcode
on it which is your identifier oh whoa
oh oh this giant horrible bone demon
which i'm sure the technical term has
like this rocket launcher pod yeah and
so there's a lot so like I guess talk a
little bit about enemy variety are you
we always taken on foes this large oh
the latter or smaller lots of very large
enemies like these these guys are pretty
big but in particular you know you see
this guy with these turrets on his
shoulders right now he's actually sawing
off that turret so that this guy can't
use it against him and then after he
picks it up he'll be able to use it to
see it right over there in front of you
he'll be able to use it to craft new
weapons afterwards so you're going to
get a huge variety if you check out our
story trailer which will be out soon if
it's not already released you're going
to see a
variety of enemies that you're fighting
kind of reminds me of angels from Ava
Kelly in a little bit you know something
I haven't seen in a long time it's just
endlessly created very cool I it just
obtained some artificial muscle there
and you've been referencing the sort of
you know we talked about it's like
grabbing stuff off of the enemy's solid
off their arm and then carrying it back
to your base that's right the crafting
is that weapon crafting primarily or
their other abilities or sort of
changing you're going to be able to do
crafts well there's going to be lots of
things you can craft I'd say mainly
weaponry is going to be a really big
part you're going to want better and
better weapons you're going to want to
upgrade your thorn you're going to want
to upgrade your you know things for your
accessory as well your AI companion so
it's a lot of different things you can
craft there's a pretty endless variety
of weapons it's one of those games that
you could play for hundreds and hundreds
of hours if you really wanted to sync
your time into it it now is that gonna
be necessary to get your sentence
reduced all the way not an awesome well
I want if you want to grind for some
some like rare lose that that is there
too yeah of course I should mention
really quickly but this game is a
collaboration between not only our Japan
studio but a studio called dimps and
shift so just to for some context the
director of the game is the director of
street fighter four shirts come on the
sauce and the Tyrells are obviously
what's that the parallels are up there
yeah and the well the designer of the
game designed a game called god eater Oh
which was free on PSP on PS plus a
little pretty recently sequel is in
Japan and then our producer from Japan
studio produced patapon so we have a
really awesome like diverse team working
on this game japan japan is salivating
over it they love it they can't wait to
see it I'm so excited to bring it you
he's got people in the game spot chat
really intrigued by it and rusher 25 has
a minor question regarding you know
sort of the Japanese and vs western
releases huh I you guys dying any having
audio available in Japanese for America
yeah that's actually a big component of
this we wanted to keep its original
Japanese flavor so it will have Japanese
audio it will be completely subtitled in
some very multiple languages we're doing
our best right now to localize it as
messed up as we can for you guys it
launches in Japan this month we'll have
it out by the end of the year very cool
zod on twitter curious about
uncompetitive mode yes so like I said
these panopticon sir are kind of you
know battling each other so sometimes
you're going to be rescuing people from
other people so for before you know not
the converses panopticon online battles
just kind of makes sense so you'll be
playing kind of games to capture the
flag with civilians sometimes you'll
just be playing death matches you know
whatever you whatever you kind of want
flying around you can afford and is
there a greater kind of a clan or betta
goetta on meta game yeah so when you
start the game you're going to be able
to select from one of the 50 cities to
actually represent from around the world
and you know we'll have very regular
updates about which which panopticon is
currently that the best so very cool
nail freedom wars a game that instantly
lit up on Twitter a lot of people very
excited about it thank you so much for
coming and showing it off here my
pleasure hi you guys are aiming for a
release this year this year absolutely
it's coming out in Japan shortly but the
American release for that's for
PlayStation Vita yep she's super Beta
completely compatible with PlayStation
TV so excited bring to you guys
excellent thank you so much my pleasure
alright